hello reject nation John who is
directing this movie well that would be
mr. Bose afirma of YouTube one emoji
youtubers and one of our favorite
comedians I've seen this guy live twice
I love love this dudes humour I hear he
has a weird approach to directing I
would expect nothing you directed Chris
Rock's latest stand-up which is a great
stand-up by the way it is all because of
oberyn's direction no yeah Chris Rock's
timing oh yeah and his material so much
is the way both the way he captured the
simple yeah as this new movie coming out
called eighth grade it's been trending
for a while let's check it out guys
wired I went to eighth grade I can
relate to this that's the last time John
and I were in school together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's get boy
[Music]
funny and cool and talking by the way I
like your shirt oh it's like so cool
[ __ ]
[Music]
I said one more week of eighth-grade
right yeah one more week crazy
yeah I think you're so cool maybe you go
out there do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at the ending of the movie yeah she
finally gets accepted like the last week
of eighth grade yeah maybe that's the
start of summer
this isn't surprise me at all that this
is about Burnham's movie and like the
the big directorial this is debut this
is like its first movie film yeah it
doesn't surprise me though I mean if you
really know Bo Burnham's variety of
songs or his bits he'll often take times
where he does like a serious song in the
middle of a comedy special or a comedy
song will then take a serious turn yeah
through or something yeah it makes a lot
of one of the best things about Bo
Burnham's
entire realm of comedy has always been
about like his perspective his point of
view and humanity's observations
sometimes his songs are kind of like a
dramedy yeah yeah he is a very
perceptive in a very world weary guy I
get the sense and also just looking at
this it seems like the social impact of
technology's gonna play a huge part to
this movie which is something that I'm
sure he knows yeah a ton about having
been you know like a young youtuber
coming up that way and also at the
advent of various social media and
things like that just from a trailer to
I was kind of surprised by how I was
feeling transported back into being
eighth grade I didn't have a cell phone
in eighth grade and I have social media
back then but if he put that to the side
that pressure to fit in that pressure to
try to socialize the arc the anxiety the
nervousness the pool parties alike I did
not look like I do now yeah I love that
he he cast this this girl looks like a
real teenager really eighth grader
yeah really for serious I read
bread though he got real eighth grader
at school yes said he was writing a
bunch of different stories on a topic
and this was the character that he was
able to identify and expound with it's
actually quite a wide range of people
that could most likely identify with
this kind of experience that's social
anxiety that fear you know it's like the
last week of eighth grade II you want to
make you count because that is a
graduation period it feels like the
culmination is thing and it makes you
look back over your whole you know
elementary career because it was a big
part of my life eighth grade you know
like we we went to school from first to
eighth grade together yeah some people
go from first to fifth and then they go
to a separate junior high we were on one
that was 1st to 8th so for me 8th grade
is like a monumental time in my life and
the last day of eighth grade and the
graduation is something I'll never
forget it's nice to see a movie that's
touching
on that time and not senior year of high
school you know oh yeah well I I feel
like there's so many things like that
it's like once you get past that point
there are so many situations you find
yourself in with various social groups
whether it's in a school environment or
not that are very much similar to those
experience that you had those
subconscious experiences I need brain
any job you get with multiple employees
will feel like a school warped version
of a time every community becomes that
at some point and I also just like the
juxtaposition of like you started this
trailer and she's like giving you tips
on how to be yourself and how to be
confident you can tell that she's
probably not that way better life at 17
years I love that point about like to be
yourself and but in order to like be
yourself if they're not trying to change
yourself to get people to like you so
that's that weird
intercom flicked of how do I just be
yeah and like by the very act of making
this little youtube channel it you
wonder like are you you're just you
trying yeah and yeah it just seems
wonderfully nuanced at least from this
first glimpse yeah here and knowing Bo
Burnham I wouldn't expect anything less
than that this is the best YouTube read
movie then you finally getting on the
body
I know it's not a YouTube no it's it's
my boys it's my it's my love a 24 a 24
homies I'm excited to see this movie
I'm looking forward to seeing this movie
yeah it seems like Bo Byrnes voices all
over it yeah and with so many you know
indie movie trailers out there this one
kind of stands apart in an odd way
because of the fact that it does seem so
authentically its subject alright guys
well what is your favorite bo burnham
song put it in the comment boxes below
so many I can't even think of one right
now I know you guys you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our vids is up Jon buzz Kyle
in full-length Q&A is over at our
patreon as well as full-length TV show
reactions over at our patreon plenty of
goodies we offer over there
take care people
there